*intense stare*
OH!
wait...
OH!?
Am I ...
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome to the RESIDENT EVIL 7 Teaser
I didn't know it was gonna start this soon.
I literally just, loaded up--
Hi, friend
How are you doing?
Are you here to kill me? Or am I here to kill you?
I don't really know considering the camera's pointed at me.
Unless i'm filming a challenge video.
The, "see who gets stabbed first" challenge.
Thank you for destroying my camera
It's only really expensive.
So, yeah, hi-- hi everybody!
I was not prepared for this
I was, expecting there to be a title screen
and then,
I-- I'm just filled with questions
Why ex- thank you excuse me thank you for that
[keep still]
How can I not keep still? I'm literally tied to a chair for-
Oohhh Jeez
Oh
okay here we go this is what I was
hoping for
Oh, okay here we go!
This is what I was hoping for!
so welcome to the resident evil 7 teaser
now this game arm
So-
Welcome to the RESIDENT EVIL 7 Teaser
Now this game,
Um..
it was released a few days ago or not
the game the teaser itself is just
It was released a few days ago- or not the game,
The Teaser itself, is just a demo
download it was released a few days ago
and it was released a few days ago
Um..
and it's really interesting because,
it's just a teaser
and a lot of people have been comparing it to P.T.
been comparing it to PT and i'll save
judgment for that until later but it's
and I'll save judgment for that untill later,
Uh...
But it's suppose to bring
supposed to bring resident evil into a
different light because as many of you
RESIDENT EVIL
Into a diffrent light
Cause as many of you may know
Ever since RESIDENT EVIL 4
it's turned more into an action game and
it seems
It's turned more into an action game
and it seems
Oh- get out of the house
Oh get out of the house well that's not
ominous thank you
Well that's not ominous
Thank you
I'll get out in my own time
I'll get out in my own time please don't
pressure me full
Please don't pressure me
Woah...
Okay
Left to walk
not now i'm playing oh hi how are you
Now...
Now im playing
Oh.. Hi!
Who are you!?
Oh-- *Laughs*
Jeez, look at the stare on that guy
Holy Shit
Oh man
You'd think he was getting his soul sucked out, instead of just a picture taken
Alrighty, then...
Hello
Hai
Oh, what lovely TV
I don't...
I don't have videotape
but apparently someone in this house
wants to murrder me
Oh Boy!
Bing Bong Bing..
Ding Dee... Aww Shit
Why did that happen
Who did that?
Alrighty, then
Oh boy, a Fooze box
"DANGER"
Whhhy?
So the stairs fuse is missing???
I didn't even know that
that could be a
Fuuuuuse...
Sorry,
When ever I get loaded up into a...
*Foot Steps*
ok
Okay!~
That doesn't scare me!
I've been through worse than that!
You're going to have to live up to a lot, if you wanna get to P.T. level of scary!
Uh huh,
That's what I thought.
Oh
That's kind of cool
Oooh, ah HEY!
*sassy* Closing doors?
Oooh
Boo-hoo sooo scary
Alright what do we got, can I see myself?
No
Is there something behind me?
No..ohohoh
Hi!
Oh that's not good...
Oh that's not good at all!
But someone has an artistic side apparently
Okay, so there's like
some sort of boarded up door here
good sign when you're waking up in a
strange place and I don't really know
why I'm here
Oh...
OH go- good
Oh great
A dummy finger...
Okay
Check Inventory
Hi!
Part of a dummy's hand
made of Celluloid
Ohhh
"Celluloid"
Ohhhh
Up stairs!
I don't like the look of that
but here we go
I'm bold and in-  Ohh
*Shivers*
Uh...
Hi!
*Nervously* How are you doing?
How are you doing?
*Thump*
what the fuck was that
What the fuck was that?
ok stairs huh
Okay
"Stairs"
Boink! :3
Huh? It did naugh-thing
it did nothing good jeez did one of you
miss a finger
Uhh jeez
Did one of you miss a finger!?
haha you bullshit god damn why did I
touch the boob
Huhahhh?
Oh shit, ah goddamn
Why did I touch the boob?
It's just a mannequin boob!
it's just a mannequin boob character guy
Character... Guy!?
Don't be so desperate about it
don't be so desperate about it geez
Uh jeez
oh good fish
Oh Gawd
Oh Gursh
oh hi how are you doing
Oh
Hi
How you doing?
Oh that's cool
oh that's cool that's gross hey wait a
minute it
That's Coo- Hahar Hey!
Wait a minute!
You weren't there before
you weren't there before you didn't
exist before they're gonna be one of
You didn't exist before
Uhhh
Is it gonna be one of those games
those games
I haven't plated him a mannequin game in
a long time
I haven't played it
Um, a mannequin game in a long time
It's an under utilized thing now-a-days!
it's an underutilized thing nowadays
people don't really do it anymore
People don't really do it any more
still freaked the hell out of me okay so
that was that
Still freaks the hell out of me, okay so that was...
What was that?
*Door Rumbles*
Ohhh!
that was that okay
That was that!
Okay
alrighty then okay jeez
Alrighty then
Ooh kay
Jeez
all right um well looks like i just
missed dinner
Alright
Umm?
Well, looks like I just missed dinner
that's a shame I was a might bit peckish
That's a shame
I was a might bit peckish
Ehu Uh-oh
Uahhh... (Disgusted)
at least there is spaghetti among the
maggots
At least there's spaghetti among the maggots
*Random Sounds*
hi who the fuck do you do oh hey
Hi..?
Who the fuck?
What do you do...oh Hey
Oh what is that that a kro-lu you know
nothing cruel especially no nothing
oh....Uh what is that?
Is that a crow?
Ouh
You know nothing crow
especially know nothing, concidering you're dead
continue your dead
Oh Jeez
oh geez oh yeah yeah yeah gross it up me
Uh.... ha
Uhe
Hu hu
Hehe Ew Gross!
Get off me!
well so far so it's it's like moderates
pooka jh
Well so far so...
It like moderate spookage
It's not a lot of spookage going on here
it's not a whole lot of spooky it's
going on here small keyhole
Small keyhole? Huh...
haha ok so i need to keep for that
Okay?
So i need a key for that,
that's good, I can't open that one
that's good i can't open that one gonna
crush them
Can I crouch in the room...ok?
okay i can run a bit
Okay
I can run a bit
That's nice
that's nice ah the ominous door at the
end of a hallway
Ah
The ominous door at the end of a hallway
Always a good sign in a horror game
always a good sign in a horror game well
nothing's happened yet to bring it on
Well nothing has happened yet, so bring it on!
oh shit I didn't mean to go in this room
this room looks like a bad Roma
Oh shit...
I didn't mean to go in this room
This room looks like a bad room!
well I been to many rooms in my day or
cheese what are these
Uh
I've been to many rooms in my day...
Oh jeez, what are these???
he's like the halves of cows why are
they here
Are these the halves of cows?
Why are they here?
oh hello me toooo bolt cutters
Uh
Hello meat ho-- Oh bolt cutters
aah panting what the fuck was that
Ah!
*Thump* Handy!
What the fuck was that!?
I didn't even see it! Oh jeez
I didn't even see it oh geez hi what the
fuck are you
HI!
What the fuck are you!?
what are you there the baby was just
baby isn't talking
What are you? Ugh it's a baby!
Well at least this baby isn't talking
the fuck was that behind me
The fuck was that behind me...?
how many times have I said the fuck was
that in this game so much bullshit
How many times have I said "The fuck was that?" in this game?
So much bullshit happening all around me
happening all around me
all right oh this is a ball
Oh there's a bo--
*Clank* Fuck you...
fuck you
right okay it's getting moderately
spooky in here
Alright... Okay it's getting moderately spoopy in here
ok I get you I can put two and two
together
Okay I got cha, I can put two and two together
pick my superior mind knows what's gonna
pop out of me
Hurg, my superior mind knows
Uh...What's ganna pop out at me? Boink
link oh oh god said okay and right
Oh, oh good, oh good, great! great!
it's I want to see this is probably good
I wanna see this
It's Probably good
Probably not someone being murdered
probably not someone being murdered oh
jeez oh jeez
Ah jeez, aw jeez
there's a lot more sounds happening and
I'm not too keen on it
There's a lot more sounds happening and i'm not to keen on it
Okay so I gotta find a place to get the key for that
ok so i gotta find a place to get the
key for that
Obviously I couldn't just use my bolt cutters to do it
obviously I couldn't just use my bolt
cutters to do it that would be too
That would be too logical
logical and I'm not full of logic
and I'm not full of logic
ok time to skedaddle SI no spooks await
baby
Okay. Time to ski-daddle. Cause I know, spooks await!
Maybe. *bangs* -mark gasps-
*Whispy noises*
that sounded less like a dog and more
like a guy doing a snarling impression
*Whispy noises and Growling*
That sounded less like a dog and more like a guy doing a snarling impression.
that probably wasn't good here and you
guys see the key
Ohhh, that probably wasn't good.
Eh, hey any of you guys seen a key?
Alright
all right let's be on my way then I got
a who
Just be on my way then.
I gotta... ooh.
Oh no.
oh no oh yeah slap your meaty hand on
that
Hey yeah, slap your meaty hand on that
Boink
*loud static*
Hey!
Oh.
yeah
I thought that was the growling okay now
what happened here
I thought that was the growling.
Ohh. Ok.
We're fine.
Now, what happened here?
*Door Closes*
thank you your soup
Thank you.
You're so- so good about that
so good about that okay fine whatever
Okay, fine.
It's whatever.
It's not spooky
that spooky not at all
It's not at all.
It's not spooky--you're not scary!
nice big you're not scary I'm gonna read
you your death steer
I'm not afraid of you!
and Your.. Death Stare
Alright, what ever
Okay
I think here
think here
My superior intellect is telling me these go together
my superior intellect is telling me
these go together just like this
Just like this
Is there where the girlfri-- Oh hey
this is where the girl for oh hey oh boy
Oh boy
*Reads Off-screen*
derelict house jun 1 del V haunted house
rehearsal
great cool
Great!
Cool
*Click*
what does that mean
What does that mean?
Oh
god damn it fuck you going to do you
remember guy
Oh god damn it. Fuck you dude! *Nervous Laughter*
give me a break people different I only
work with professionals
God Damn It
Ahhh Jesus
speaking of which make sure the sound is
right this time I don't want a repeat of
Amarillo two fucking years ago I don't
do a dr oh oh I'm playing not feeling Oh
Ah huh
Oh
Oh! I'm playing
Ahh
No
Ohhhh
right we have to make a change for geez
why am I in control of the past because
Oh jeez
Why am I in control of the past?
Unless it's not the past
it's not the pass side first wall and
shoot the interim was just like we
Woah wow!
Oh, I should probably follow them
always just ok try to say the show's
name this time okay
Ok
ah no problem wait for me
Ah huh
Wait for me!
cheese other work with fucking Channel
happen
Oh Jeez
sorry I'm sorry guys I wasn't paying
attention what they're talking about i
Sorry! I'm sorry guys, I wasn't paying attention what they were talking about
I was distracted
was distracted
Okay
ok cool what do we do and we filming a
TV show
Cooool
What are we doin'?
We flimin' a TV show?
cool cool
COOOOL
cool
are we rolling let's go
Euhh
ok get out of the wing
Okay
Yeah loser!
yeah loser for a man to do this lot like
they're very manly
Time for a man to do this.
Like that *laughs*
See. Manly.
Thanks, bruh
thank you raw after me know after all
come on it so we'll be like that
after me, no after. Aww. come on man
why you gotta be like that?
why are we in hell this time you ever
practice
what's the prep shitty house will be
sound
who is it haunted
oh it's the house we're in. okay
oh it's the house where in okay I get it
I get it
I was an acre you know we can sub Pete
not anchor what's that
nothing she's fine hello back of that
guy whose name was just said sorry and
oh jeez
Hi, hello
back.. of that  guy whose name was just said and I can't remember it
hurt . and farmhouse missing family
Andre
foul play suspected the usual huh
jeez
*inhale*
huh
how long do you say this place has been
abandoned for three years
*characters cough*
eww
plantae get a shot of this is that my
dad away
Is that my name?
You got it.
you got it rules hill billy joe and his
family go missing not Hillbillies the
Ohhh look at this
oh jeez
Baker's Jack and Margaret Baker no bugs
is done
No bugs this time
they were quiet not faculty lot of bad
rumors about their son Lucas bad seed
ah-huh
apparently
shit uh-huh no I shouldn't wear my good
shoes
Ha ha
oh jeez
she's oh yeah
Huh, what the hell?
Oh! Why cant I walk here?!
why can't I walk here in my shots hey
wait a minute oh why can't i work here
Hey!
Wait a minute
Why cant I walk here?!
at drop
oh that's right what do you think I
don't know
Huh?
ohh.
oh I get it I'm sure ah i see Andre
Andre Andre went
Oh I get it
Ahhh. I see
I see.
Andre!
No. Not at all.
no not at all i just saw the invisible
wall that meant we were gonna get
I just saw the invisible wall that meant we were gonna get seperated
separated on fucking believable
I know, right
I know right it's the last time I work
with that guy huh
Ah huh
I mean teachers and they come and go but
a good cameraman like you can see it's
Should I check up--
okay
okay all right
Alright. Cool.
goal thank you you're so nice and kind I
love you
Thank you, you're so nice and kind
I love you
We're probably gonna die
we're probably gonna die oh the dolls
aren't there anymore
Oh, the dolls aren't there anymore
ok what was that
okay
*loud crash*
Wow!
did you do that no I was just listening
to the sounds of music cross shut up
No! I was just listening to the sounds of music ac-across the-- shut up!
asshole fuck you
Asshole. Fuck you!
I'm--I'm not.
and I'm not even interested enough in
being sarcastic get you the fuck is he
I'm not even
I'm not even--
interested enough in being sarcastic at you
I don't know why would why would even be
behind the closed doors why would he be
I don't know
Why would-- Why would he be be ba behind
the closed doors
why would he be in the back alleys of the house?
in the back alleys of as how do you have
gotten there
How'd he've gotten there?
I mean obviously the answer someone took
him took him away
I mean obviously the answer is someone took him
took him away
is he gonna get sucked up in there
always gonna get stuck at the helm
uhhh
is he gonna get sucked up in there?
oh he's gonna get sucked up, isn't he
what
oh
ahhhh!
ok new deal
ok
ahhhh
we find Andre and we go me fuck this
show
ok or we could just leave now
okay
or we could just leave nooww
that's an option
that's an option I'm not really
emotionally attached one way or another
I'm not really emotionally attached one way or another to Andre
to Andre why are you going in the murder
hole
Why are you going in the murder hole?!
This is clearly a murder hole
this is clearly a murder hole why would
you walk in the murder and Howard Andre
Why would you walk in the murder-- and how would Andre get back here?!!
get back here
This all highly illogical
this is all highly illogical I've got a
lot of experience and horror games
I've got a lot of experience in horror games
Oh great...
oh great oh this is wonderful
Oh this is wonderful
oh this is too light for you first of
all oh I was already going to worry
oh this is delightful
oh
oh, I was already going don't worry about me
about me coming down the ladder
uh huh yeah sure will do okay great
Ah-huh, yeah sure. Will do.
okay, great!
Don't mind me as I.. run off into death
don't mind me as i run off into death
alone scared
Alone
scared
oh
oh oh oh geez
uhhh
ohhh
ohh
oh jeez
oh oh this is so the ring
oh this so the ring are not to bring
this so Blair Witch Project
or not ring. This is so Blair Witch Project
oh man
oh man why is he hanging on his
tippy-toes is he hanging by something is
Why is he hanging on his tippy toes
is he hanging by something?! Is he hanging by a meat hook?!!
hanging by a meat hook
whoa I don't like that can go back now
Woahhh. I don't like that
Can I go back up now? *nervous laughter*
what is it ah what happens if i just go
back up
uhhh
What happends if I just back up?!
You don't want to go down there man!
you know I go down there man it's bad
news man with its get the fuck out of
It is badddd news man.
Let's get the fuck out of here, bruh *nervous laugh*
here brother dude are you kidding me
Dude.
Are you kidding me?
don't go down there fine
Don't go down there!!
Aww fine. What am I a baby?
what am i a baby all right
Alright
I'll confront it
maybe he's just fine and everything is a 100% A-ok
everything's not okay
everything is not A-ok
100% not ok A-ok
hundreds and not a okay Andre plants and
whatever the hell that guy's name is oh
Andre, Clancy, and whatever the hell guy's name is
oh, god damn it!
god dammit
oh and there is a meaty-- oh what is that?
there's a medium what is that where you
do
Where I go?
hello hi hello
hello, hi. Hello.
*crunchy noise*
yeah just lay on my lap for a little bit
it'll be okay all right
Oh! Uhhhhhh huhhhuhu hu hu!!!!
hu hu hu hu hu
Yeah, just lay on my lap for a little bit. It'll be okay.
oh, hi
hello hope hi
hello
Hi
*commotion and grunting*
how you
Ow. Eww.
Eww and oww.
you are now
ok oh hello bye
Oh!
Hello!
HI!
I shall - you against the stones
(Note reads) "I SHALL DASH YOU AGAINST THE STONES."
*Nervous chuckle* Well isn't that lovely?...
well isn't that lovely thank you that
means so much to me to know you care
Thank you!...
That means so much to me
To know you care...
right away
Alright, oh wait
um
oh I don't know what that is
Oh. I don't know what that is. I looks like a...
it looks like a looks like a face with
really full lips
It looks like a face
With really full lips. Lushes lips
luscious lips I don't know maybe I see a
pair of boobs i'm not sure what that
I dunno maybe I see a pair of boobs? I'm not sure what that says about me
says about me but because our pair of
boobs
but I think I saw a pair of boobs...okay!?
okay well least now I know where the
thing is so maybe I'll find something
well at least now I know...
where the thing is
so maybe i'll find something
so if i go down here...haha...hello
so if i go down here haha hello I wonder
what would happen what would happen to
I wonder what would happen what would of happened if Ida...if Ida..played this again
find a if I to play this again and I go
straight for that what would happen
and I go straight to that what would happen?
cuz obviously it's there
because obviously it's there so I know
about it into the murder hole we go
so I know about it?
ahh...into the murder hole we go!
I'm sure this will turn out better for me
I'm sure this will turn out better for
me hello
oh hello...back door key
backdoor key handy that okie dokie
hand that!
okie dokie!
aw Jeez I can't go down there?
jeez I can't go down there but I want to
go down so badly
but I wanna go down so badly!
aw it looks so much fun down there
all right looks so much fun down there
people's heads being rammed on the pipes
Peoples heads being rammed on to pipes and shit!
and shit
gray
GREAT!
a great huh
GREAT! HUH?
okay all right okay all right
OKAY...ALRIGHT
okay
alright
*crashing sounds*
ok did the murder fall down and break
his hip
ohhhkay
Did the murder fall down and break his hip?
Oh, was that there
Oh was that there I don't recall that
being there
I don't recall that being there
Ohhhh...why does grandma have a bag over her head?
whoo - grandma have a bag over her head
who hey o friend is gone
Ohhh. Hey hey hey.
OH friend is gone!
where did friend go I wonder where
Where did friend go?
*nervous laugh* I wonder where...
aww jeez
geez why did friend disappear friend
pretty friend go
Why did friend disappear?
Friend?!
Where did friend go??
oh jeez oh jeez alrighty then
ohhh jeez...aww jeez
okay
Alrighty then
it can't be so easy that I walk out the
back door i know for a fact that's not
it can't be....
so easy that I walk out the back door. I know for a fact that's not gonna happen
going to happen
*groans*
fact will he
In fact--ohh hey
*bangs*
hi, whoa god damn it! Where did you come from?!
damn it where did you come from
Hey, friend! Welcome back!
hey friend welcome back who threw you
did you fall or joyous day
Who threw you?
Did you fall??
Oh joyous day
hoho joyous d alrighty then
ohoho joyous day
alrighty then
looky dokie well here we go
Okie dokie. Welp here we go
onwards to victory!!
onwards to victory this is gonna go
crane
*sarcasm* This is gonna go great!
ya feel me finger link
Yeah!!
Dummy finger
boink
looky who is it
hoookay
here we go
*character laughs*
geo some of the family it was that the
guy from the painting probably carry the
oh jeez
Oh hi! *loud punch* *markiplier laughs*
was that the guy from the painting? Probbably
*character groaning*
Oh. Hurry the frick up, dude.
freaking out dude would you drop it
Why'd you drop it?
oh I don't get hot here
Oh oh
That doesn't sound good.
Yeah no joke... maybe you wanna
yeah no joke maybe you want to
oh oh
that's not good was that it couldn't
have been
Well that's not good... ummm
*stabbing and moaning*
*breathing heavily and growling*
Oh , hi!
Was that it?!
That couldn't have been it
*long beep*
Is that it?
it
Oh open the door to the resident evil
ambassador program
Awww!
*reads offsceen*
what does that mean?!
what does that mean what the Frick kazan
mean what the hell's of Resident Evil
what the frick does that mean?!
what the hell is the resident evil ambassador program!?
ambassador program
This is... bullshit!
this is bullshit what the Frick they can
have been in what
waht the frick
That can't have been it
WHAT??!!!
okay I'm gonna go back in because i want
to know who hey i wanna know
Okay, hang on. I'm gonna back in, beause I wanna know--
Oh hey
I wanna know... I bet
I bet no there must be a reason why
people are comparing this to PT because
that--there must be a reason why people where comparing this to PT because...
I picked up like there was a lot of
things that I didn't do
I picked up- like there was a lot of things that I didn't do
I didn't open the drawer
I didn't open the drawer I got that
finger probably should have used it on
I had that finger
I probably should have used it on one of the dummies or something
one of the dummies or something
I have no idea... but if I go right over here
I have no idea but if I go right over
here and go right there
I can go right there
Bam!
I am what does that do does it great -
god damn game already do
What does that do? Does it break the god damn game? I bet it do.
Oh shit. That don't sound good.
oh shit i don't so good hello
Hello!
haha i'm beating your system breath in
your system
Ha ha ha. I'm beating your system, brah.
Beating your system!
hello I should did I wonder why that got
there then and not before
Ohhh, hello!
Ohhh shit, dude!
I wonder why that got there then and not ..before
Ah! Because there are secrets
because there are secrets in the game
that need to be explored
in the game, that need to be explored!
soooo
so if i put this fuse in the fuse box
like that and then it's labeled stairs
if I put this fuse
in the fuse box... boink. Like, that
and then it's labeled stairs
there's a button for stairs upstairs and
if i press out what the hell does it do
there's a button for stairs , upstairs
and if I press that, what the hell does it do?
Ah. Yes. These are all good mysteries.
ah yes these are all good mysteries
*footsteps*
Alexis I'm not scared of you nothing's
going to happen I know my fears and
I'm not scared of you. Nothing's gonna happen
I know my fears!
And you're not part of 'em!
you're not part of them
I'm marching off into the distantance
I'm marching off into the distance I'm
gonna pick up this goddamn finger
and I'm gonna pick up this goddamn finger!
I'm not figure that fuck out
I'm gonna... FINGER THE F*CK OUT
all right
Alright
Can I--oh. Examine ooohhh, hello
Oh examine who hello hi
Hi. What the hell?
what the help
*crash*
hi I'll be with you in a moment move
HI! I'll be with you in a moment.. ooof
You! You did it!
you see who did it maybe I need to point
at the thing in the universe
Maybe I need to point at the thing
in the universe. Oh, what is that?
what is that had a key
is that a key? who is that som--
was that some to something it looks like
there's like a key in the back
Is that something ? It looked like there was a key in the back
I could throw it away norfolk and throw
it away
I could throw it away. Nope, can't throw it away.
Alright. Fine then.
all right fine then ah yes good
Ah, yes, good.
Hello! Welcome to the party. We got a secret to explore
hello welcome to the party we've got a
secret to explore
Boink! Okay.
ok shit shit shit
Soo... ooh shit.
Oh shit
Whoa, hey! Wow!
whoa wow cool
Coool! Oh.
oh hi oh geez hello
Hi. Oh jeez.
Hello, cool!
cool guys want a finger mother finger
mother finger
Guys wan't a finger
Want a finger, huh? Want a finger
Eeeeeeeh *presses profusely*
ok by then I'll be a i'll be up here
where their stuff and things
Okay, bye then!
I'll be... I'll be up here
Where there is stuff and things. Uhh.
*phone rings*
phone guy
Phone guy?!
somehow I always do
Somehow I always knew !
*phone continues ringing*
Oh jeez. Man let me see everything first.
Whoa.
whoa that don't look friendly that don't
look friendly at all
That don't look friendly
that don't look friendly at all
well shit
well shit no that's gonna do for me okay
great
wonder what's that gonna do for me?
*character footsteps*
okaayyy
Alright. Hello! Oh jeez.
hello war cheese fine
Okay. We're fine. We're okay. Alright.
ok right oh hi
*suspensful music*
Oh. Hi!
Hello.
hello how are you doing okay
How're you doin?
ok
you do something to me what's with the
odds the Umbrella Corporation ok
You gonna do somethin' to me?
*phone rings*
ooohhh
What's with the... ahh! That's the Umbrella Corporation! Okay
hello are they watching us from that
helicopter is here watching us
Ahh uuhh hello
ahhhh
*reads text* ARE THEY WATCHING US FROM THAT HELICOPTER?
Is who watching us?
The govern-me-ment
the government government
the govment
I don't know
all right hello hello
*phone continues ringing*
Alright, hello
*flirty* Ah, hello
I know you I who for you
you have the power to keys but they are
coming with that choice may not be with
you
Ah huh. Okay. *dial tone*
uh-huh ok what does that mean what does
it mean what choice good choice sure
What does that mean?
What does that mean?!
What choice?!
What choice do I have?!
have
I don't know that's what that nipple can
anyone to talk to anybody they call a
I don't know.
*nervous laugh* How would I know? Can anyone-- Can I talk to anybody?
Can I call a number?
number
shit I'm fucked
*dial tone*
Shit!
I'm fucked.
alrighty then so that means he's got to
come to the family laughs like where you
Alrighty then.
Sooo...      ahhh
So that means there's gotta be---
*Screams* F*CK! Where the f*ck did you come from?!
come from what the fuck are you kidding
me
What the f*ck are you kidding me?!
what make it got them sense where the
fuck did he come from
WHAT?! That didn't make any goddamn sense! Where the f*ck did he come from?!
what what the hell we got to get out of
here
What?!
*laughs* What the hell?!
What was that?
okay so apparently apparently that is
how that supposed to end the guy just
Okay. So apparently
Apparently that is how that's supposed to end
The guy just ambushes you after you answer the phone
ambushes you after you answer the phone
and it doesn't seem like anyone knows
And
It doesn't seem like anyone knows what the finger does....
what the finger does
it's weird that's weird
That's weird
That's weird!
Okay. So there is only one other thing in here that it seems like it want's me to see
ok so there's only one other thing in
here that it seems like it wants me to
see
Ahh, so we're gonna find out what it is
so we're gonna find out what it is and
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to do
and what I'm going to do, is I'm going to
do some things here that it's going to be totally rad and you're gonna see what
some things here it's gonna be totally
rad you guys are going to see what but
but there's an axe
there's an axis that you can get but
people don't know what the purposes you
that you can get, that people don't know what the purpose is.
can swing around a whole bunch but Kelly
doesn't seem to do much so i'm actually
you can swing it around a whole bunch but-
apparently it doesn't seem like it'll do much
so I'm actually gonna try a few things, here. I'm gonna open this up
gonna try a few things here i'm gonna
open this up I'm gonna get the stairs
I'm gonna get the stairs and then I'm gonna go get the phone ringing and then I'm gonna go get the axe
and I'm gonna go get the phone ringing
and then I'm gonna go get the axe and
and see if I can progress the story any further that way
see if I can progress the story any
further that way that would be a drink -
cause that will be a dream... did I even grab the key?
I even grabbed the key now there is no
key
oh there is no key. Ok that's interesting.
ok that's interesting so there's no key
their owner five doomed myself now
So there's no key there
I wonder if I've doomed myself
Ah well. We'll figure it out.
welcome to get up
ah uh-huh
Ahhh Oh ho!
Hey! Ok. So lock pick
hey ok so lock pick then you go over
here
Then you go over here
do this thing you pick this lock and
apparently there will be nothing in it
do this thing
you pick this lock
and apparently they'll be nothing in it, right now?
right now but in the future it'll be
unlocked for so everything Gregory's on
but in the future
it'll be unlocked for some f--- f*cking reason
fucking believable believable i don't
know i work with that guy
*mockingly* Un-f*cking believable.
I know...      I know right
I know right right so now we grab the
key if we want to i didn't really matter
alright. So now we grab the key if we want to.. it doesn't really matter I guess at this point
i guess at this point but now that we've
got all that done well well what the
but now that we've gotten all that done
Whoa whoa whoa! WHAT THE F*CK?!
fuck that stuff that was the guy
What the f*ck was that?!!
That was the guy!
*creepy music*
fostering in anybody's gonna get there
what the fuck
Phone's still ringing
Anybody gonna get that? What the f*ck?!
*noises*
sheezus is going on up there
jesus
what is going on up there?
I'm gonna go explore that in a second
but in here right around here
I'm gonna explore that in a second.. but in here
right around here....there should be. Aha!
there should be a high and you act
*lisps* An axe! I can attack with it!
I can't attack with it I don't know
people said there's no used to it
I don't know. People said there's no use to it
so I don't know
I don't know let me go up and explore
the upper area
let me go up and explore the upper area
there was a crash in a bang up here
wondering if so what you see is easy
there was a crash and a bang up here
wandering if s-so-- did you see anything?
*grunts*
yeah yeah yeah shit
Oh shit
would you pat ok and oh yeah okay
oh jeez. hya. okay
Ehh. Oohhh, nice *chuckles*
oohh yeah
*grunts* okay
yep I am bench ok
Bamn, b*tch! Okay
Hyaa!
oh yeah
Hello *smashes boxes*
hello Max's that's all
habisky
Habisky!
Boxes!
Oh bowska... oh
holy shit I didn't expect that actually
do anything
Holy shit
I d-didn't expect that'd actually do anything
what the fuck nice legs
What the f****ck. Nice legs
what the f*ck
huh
huh?
fascinating ok so now that I have the
axe
fascinating... okay so
now that I have the axe... ummm i really don't know what else to do its
i I really don't know what else to do
its I don't think anybody knows what
i don't think anybody knows what else to do I-I
else you
I'm that supposedly there's a way to
quote unquote beat the demo but no one's
supposedly
there's a way to quote un quote
"beat the demo"?
but no one's been able to... you know... to figure it out yet
been able to you know figure it out yet
there's something to do with the dummy finger but I'm not 100 percent sure on that one
something to do with the dummy finger
but i'm not sure no one
so
so that is all that I know to get right
now so now it's either choice going out
that is... all that I know
to get right now... so
now it's either the choice to going out the backdoor
the back door trying the phone call but
either way
trying the phone call but either way--ahhh fuck off!
god dammit that got me already have a
key right your booty
god damn it that got me already
Habusky!
Ha, right in your booty!
(mark makes attacking noises)
oh hey all ok
okay
alright. So I'm gonna go to the route of the phone call then this- I don't think this axe
all right so I'm gonna go the route of
the phone call then this
I don't think this ax is going to help
in any way to defeat the guy but there's
is going to help in any way to defeat the guy
but there's a possibility that this phone call might be different
a possibility this phone call might be
different
so
so under the same thing
Nah same thing...
who are you who are you Kovac you can
repair improvement leave here with a boy
who are you?
I'm gonna bo--whoa. Oh that's my hand
that's my hand on the bag myself into a
corner you'll never be able to get me
I'm gonna back myself into a corner
he'll never be able to get me
find a corner
if I'm in a corner....    he can't
he can't know how do you wait how are
you alive again
you know-- how'd, you wait. How are you alive again?
I smashed you up I got my back to the
wall
I smashed you up!
If I got my back to the wall
you'll never get me
he'll never get me
*crashes*
yeah you better get out of the way hello
yup, yeah. You better get out of the way
Whoa, hello
Blah!
I stick up your butt
Nice stick up your butt
blah!
I'm like a wild animal when I'm cornered
no telling what i'll do youjizz passion
but I don't seem good while he's gonna
no tellin' what I'll do
oh jeez
Ah shit!    Well that don't seem good
Well he's gonna get me
get me
I have a funny feeling
hello
hello oh shit
oh
oh oh
oh shit
a fucking which is what she's well I
mean I'm not dead yet
aw f*ck
oh jeez
well I mean
I'm not dead yet!
I'm not dead yet why am I not dead yet
I'm not dead yet! Why am I not dead yet?!
what is this made Woody's
What does this mean?
oh jeez
ok
okay
*crash*
Wah!
ok oh geez I don't know what's going on
okay
aww jeez
I don't know what's going on
I'm very confused
Huh
yeah
I seem to have survived but I can't
exactly leave her all just died again
I seem to have survived
but... I can't exactly leave or else I'll just die again, right?
right
probably... what happens if I put the key in there and then don't go out the door?
huh?! Maybe you're scared of me
maybe he's afraid
that's probably it, right?
*screams*
okay like you okay
Okay well-- f*ck you goddamn it!
okay, well shit
well shit right yeah ok enough for you
enough for you enough you
alright
okay
enough of you
ok
ok so that is all for this I don't know
how to get any farther I don't think
so that is all for this. I don't know how to get any farther. I don't think anybody knows how to get any farther
anybody knows how to get any farther but
for now this is looking promising it's
but for now this is looking promising. It's not "quite "
not quite as poopy scary as PT was but
it's still looking like it might be
as spoopy scary as PT was but it's still
looking like it might be pretty good
pretty good especially considering its a
departure from normal resident evil like
especially considering it's a departure from the normal Resident Evil
like
a theme that they've had going on so
thank you everybody so much for watching
theme that they've had going on
So, thank you everybody so much for watching. If you want to check out PT
if you want to check out PT the video is
available in the description or in the
the video is available in the description or in the end, in the station over there
annotation over there check it out
check it out, it's lots of fun
lots of fun thank you again and as
always I will see you in the next video
Thank you again. And as always... I'll see you in the next video!
Bye Bye!